jean michel jean baptiste bonjour
bonjour vous êtes candidat aux élections
législatives vous vous présentez sur la
circonscription 3 celle de fort de
france sans étiquette sans étiquette
exactement ça alors pourquoi vous
présentez-vous à ce scrutin lorsque ya
une souffrance les du peuple et en tant
que martiniquais je ne peux pas y rester
insensible
donc je dois et je me dois d'apporter ma
pierre à l'édifice et ça va tous les cas
se situer dans un projet se voulait pas
il s'agit d'élections législatives
donc c'est pour aller voter des lois des
amendements enfin tout ce que que ça
continue vous pensez que les élus que
nous avons n'ont pas rempli leur mission
jusqu'à présent en fait c'est pas moi
qui vais tirer sur les élus à chacun sa
conscience on pense qu'il faut changer
de deux politiques aujourd'hui il faut
être plus audacieux et il faut qu'il y
ait un rapport entre l'élu que je serai
bien le dit et puis et la france il faut
que la france comprenne que nous sommes
des partenaires nous partîmes ameil la
france donc et la france n'a jamais et
aussi bien
ne s'est jamais aussi bien senti quand
il ya de la confrontation donc il faut
que qu'on arrête avec cette
infantilisation nous sommes des manques
en tout - le puy un cerveau ou pas
réfléchi je pense que la martinique doit
et se doit d'avoir ce genre de
début de député alors quelles seraient
vos deux ou trois projets prioritaires
que vous souhaitiez défendent si vous
êtes élu à l'assemblée nationale pour
l'ensemble du territoire y en a
tellement mais un deux ou trois il y en
a tellement mais moi je me contenterai
déjà dénoncer la vie chère il faut se
battre contre la vie chère et il y as si
vous voulez un parallèle qu'ils vont
trouver entre vie chère et pouvoir
d'achat on se vous pouvez régler le
problème de la vie chère mais si vous ne
réglez pas le problème du pouvoir
d'achat donc c'est qu'on soit disant
même bague est là donc ça et la retraite
donc tous à la retraite c'est aussi du
pouvoir d'achat et puis l'emploi des
jeunes on ne peut pas rester là et puis
dire que
et tout va bien nous jeunes belles pays
soleil tout ça non il faut qu'il y ait
autre chose les soirs où nos jeans
concernant la circonscription de fort de
france pensez vous qu'il ya des
priorités spécifiques je ne dirais pas
priorités spécifiques voir s'il ya
tellement de choses à faire à fort de
france il ya les jeunes il y a et les
personnes âgées en fin de set et nagy
dit à moi je pense qu'il manque
d'infrastructures afin de fois ce n'est
pas la faute au maire je le dis hein le
maire il a la bonne volonté mais des
fois donc les moyens financiers ne subit
pas adopter en tant que député je mate
élevé à aider fort de france aussi la
menthe et nick oui mais fort de france
aussi qu'avez vous à dire aux électeurs
si vous avez à vous adresser à eux pour
les convaincre de voter je leur dis que
je suis déterminé mais avec beaucoup
d'humilité et que je souhaite qu'ils
nous fassent constitue confiance tout ça
c'est que c'est un groupe 1 c'est pas
d'accord son représentant donc qu'il
nous fasse confiance et puis c'est notre
manière de faire et puis si de l'audace
et l'audace et rendre possible ce qui
paraît impossible jean michel jean
baptiste merci merci madame pitt